Patricia la rivière et Jean-Baptiste
armé son chef de deux jeunes PME dans un
contexte de crise et alors que de
nouvelles réformes sont en cours comment
tirer son épingle du jeu la CGPME des
Yvelines a donc organisé une réunion
pour éclairer ses membres sur les
dispositions gouvernementales à venir et
c'est important qu'ils en échangent
effectivement parce qu'on a des choses à
dire surtout vis-à-vis des événements
qui se passent en ce moment des lois qui
vont être décidées qui vont être mises
en place on a besoin de réagir et de
s'exprimer vis-à-vis de ça la
compétitivité on a simplement une
problématique de prix je veux dire les
prix tombent de plus en plus la deuxième
problématique c'est que on est beaucoup
on commence à attaquer beaucoup par les
pays de l'Est
donc qui ont des coûts entre 4 et 6 fois
moins cher que nous et qui viennent sur
le marché français pour vendre de
l'impression grand format avec les
systèmes UPS avec ce genre de choses ils
arrivent à des délais très courts la
qualité quasiment la même sauf que ils
ont une main d'oeuvre qui est quand même
beaucoup beaucoup moins cher que nous on
a tous les mêmes machines donc forcément
on veut tous faire tourner des machines
donc forcément le marché diminue les
prises cassent un peu la figure
mais bon il suffit de se battre quoi de
trouver des nouveaux marchés des
nouvelles niches et on arrive à s'en
sortir outre la compétitivité toujours
ce problème récurrent la relation avec
les banques qui conditionnent la
trésorerie des entreprises le contact
avec les banques est extrêmement
difficile et le contact avec les
assureurs aussi sont extrêmement
difficiles moi j'entends des grosses
grands discours et sur le terrain je ne
vois pas ce qui est dit dans les grands
discours notamment vis-à-vis des banques
vis-à-vis des administrations la
simplification elle n'est pas encore en
place d'ailleurs c'est pour ça que mes
clients sont un peu débordés parmi les
réformes en cours qui font des bas le
projet de loi de finances 2013 il était
notamment prévu une hausse de la
taxation des sessions immobilières
passant de 19% aujourd'hui après de 60%
après une très forte mobilisation de la
CGPME et des autres syndicats patronaux
la proposition du gouvernement a
finalement été abandonnée
ça